let's say that X is a function of the
parameter T and it's equal to cosine of
T and Y is also defined as a function of
T and it's equal to sine of T and we
want to find the arc length of the curve
traced out so length of curve from T is
equal to zero to T is equal to PI over
two so pause this video and see if you
can work that out based on formulas that
we seen in other videos all right so
first I'm going to look at the formula
and then we're going to visualize it and
appreciate why what we got from the
formula actually makes sense so the
formula tells us that arc length of a
parametric curve arc length is equal to
the integral from our starting point of
our parameter T equals a to our ending
point of our parameter T equals B of the
square root of the derivative of X with
respect to T squared plus the derivative
of Y with respect to T squared DT DT
this could also be re-written as this is
equal to the integral from A to B of the
square root of DX DT squared plus dy DT
squared DT but either way we can now
apply it in this context what is DX DT
so DX DT is equal to the derivative of
cosine of T is equal to negative sine of
T negative sine of T and what is dy DT
the derivative of Y with respect to T
derivative of sine of T is cosine of T
cosine of T so our arc length up here is
going to be equal to the integral from T
is equal to zero to PI over two that's
what we care about our parameter is
going from zero to PI over two of the
square root of the derivative of X with
respect to T
that's a negative sign of t squared well
if you square it the negative is going
to go away you're going to negative sign
times negative sign is positive sine
squared so I could write this as sine
squared of T and then dy DT squared
that's just cosine squared T plus cosine
squared T and then we have our DT out
here now lucky for us sine squared plus
cosine squared of some variable is
always going to be equal to one so that
just that's one of our most basic trig
identities comes straight out of the
unit circle definition of sine and
cosine and so we have the square root of
one the principal root of one which is
just going to be one so all of this
thing everything here is just simplified
to digital from zero to PI over two DT
well this is going to be equal to so you
could view it this is a one here the
antiderivative of 1 with respect to T is
just going to be T we're going to
evaluate that from PI over 2 we're going
to evaluate that at PI over 2 and then
subtract it evaluated at 0 so this is
going to be equal to PI over 2 minus 0
that's going to be equal to PI over 2
now let's think about why that actually
does make sense let's plot this curve so
that is my y-axis this is my x-axis
right over here
when T is equal to 0 you have X of 0
cosine of 0 X is equal to 1 X is equal
to 1 and Y sine of 0 is 0 so y is equal
to 0 so at this point right over here at
t is equal to 0 and then as T increases
up to PI over 2 we trace out the top
right corner of the unit circle and we
end up right over here when T is equal
to PI over 2 you could view T in this
case as some type of an angle in radians
and so the arc length is really just the
length of quarter of a quarter of a unit
circle well we know what the
circumference of a circle is
it is 2 pi R in the unit circle case the
radius is 1 so the circumference of the
entire circle is 2 pi 1/4 of that is
going to be pi over 2 so it's nice when
we this fancy thing that we feel good
about in calculus is consistent with
what we first learned in basic geometry